komplett autonom fahren Autos wären
grandios keine Frage aber wo sind denn
die robotaxis die autonomen
Paketlieferanten und wann fährt mein
Tesla endlich komplett alleine ich
selbst habe ja dran geglaubt dass wir na
ja jetzt schon damit unterwegs sind ich
sage mal die ersten richtigen Level 4
Autos auf der Straße gibt es
2021 2022 sagen wir mal 2022 falsch war
das nicht die Autos sind zwar da aber
noch nicht hier also hier in Deutschland
vor unserer Haustür und Skeptiker haben
immer noch berechtigte Zweifel daran
dass Sie das jemals sein werden aktuell
ziehen sich mehrere Unternehmen aus dem
autonomen Game zurück oder entlassen
Teile ihrer Belegschaft was ist da los
wir steigen ein aber anscheinend nicht
vergessen
[Musik]
vielleicht wurde dir schon mal eins
dieser Videos hier in die Timeline
gespült robotaxis ohne Fahrer die nicht
nur den Weg finden sondern auch komplett
selbstständig fahren die mit
Verkehrshindernissen klar kommen
Schilder verstehen Unfälle vermeiden
obwohl ich schon viele dieser Videos
gesehen habe bin ich immer wieder
richtig meint blauen Unternehmen wie
raymo oder Cruise verfolgen
vollautomatisiertes fahren auf Level 4
von 5 sie wollen einen eigenen robotaxi
Service aufbauen mit dem man ohne Fahrer
durch die Stadt gefahren wird deutlich
günstiger als Mitfahrer das ist die
Hoffnung anfangs machten sie das noch
mit Sicherheitsfahrer inzwischen aber
nur noch mit externer Kontrolle in
Deutschland können wir solche Services
aber leider noch nicht nutzen wie kann
es also sein könnte man sich natürlich
fragen dass diese amerikanischen Firmen
scheinbar so viel weiter sind
die kurze Antwort sie sind es nicht die
lange Antwort es kommt auf den Ansatz an
der Ansatz den die robotaxis verfolgen
sieht so aus die Gebiete in denen sie
fahren werden stark limitiert jede
Straßen muss vorher mit hochauflösenden
Scans kartografiert werden in diesem
Gebiet kennen sich die Autos also aus
aber selbst in dieser stark limitierten
Umgebung bleiben sie noch häufig stecken
und auch das Wetter ist immer noch eine
Herausforderung Regen oder Nebel
irritieren z.B die Sensoren der Ansatz
der deutschen Hersteller wiederum
konzentriert sich vor allem auf Features
auf Level 2 und 3 dazu gehören Stau
Assistenten attraktive Tempo Kontrolle
oder automatisiertes fahren auf der
Autobahn übrigens mit deutlich
unauffälligeren Sensoren seit Juli 2021
ist in Deutschland das Level 3 fahren
auf der Autobahn mit bis zu 60 km/h
erlaubt also nur im Stau sinnvoll seit
diesem Jahr sind aber auch bis zu 130
km/h möglich
der fahrzeugexperte Professor Steven
Peters schätzt trotzdem dass die
europäischen Hersteller sich auch in
Zukunft weiter auf solche Features
konzentrieren werden anstatt den Sprung
zu Level 4 oder sogar fünf zu machen ich
erwarte einen klaren Fokus auf
Sonderausstattung wie autobahnpiloten
bis 130 km/h sowie Komfortfunktionen für
automated Valley parking für die Stadt
erwarte ich von den OEM er evolutionäre
Weiterentwicklung etwa von
Bremsassistenten die robotaxis von Remo
und Cruise scheinen komplett
revolutionär der europäische Ansatz ist
aber eher eine logische Konsequenz
bisheriger Assistenz Programme eben eine
Evolution setzen sich Mercedes BMW und
Co also einfach nur realistische Ziele
naja nicht ganz denn auch hier hakt es
noch bisher hat sich kein Hersteller mit
einem Level 3 System an die 130 km/h
herangetraut der ki-experte Professor
Philipp meint das liegt auch daran dass
kein Hersteller seinen Namen riskieren
will
doch mal zu einem Unfall kommen sollte
das bremst natürlich die
Weiterentwicklung er meint wir brauchen
Zertifizierungen und Garantien für das
Verhalten von ki-systemen um sie in
Hinblick auf ihre Sicherheit vergleichen
zu können kurz gesagt das Problem ist
dass autonomes fahren nach wie vor echt
mega komplex ist vielleicht komplexer
als manche vor einigen Jahren dachten
empfindliche Sensorik schwierige
Verkehrssituationen oder Imageschäden
sind nur einige Aspekte die dabei
bedacht werden müssen um das Problem zu
lösen gibt es verschiedene Ansätze
entweder wir schränken das Gebiet oder
die Komplexität der Fahraufgabe stark
ein immerhin lässt sich jedes System
immer weiter zerlegen in noch kleinere
Teilaufgaben bis sie irgendwann von
einer KI sicher zu bewältigen sind aber
wenn es in dem Bereich so viel zu tun
gibt die kommt es dann das ganze
Programme eingestampft werden
Unternehmen ihre Türen schließen oder
Mitarbeiter entlassen werden
natürlich können wir hier nur
spekulieren vielleicht haben sich einige
nicht auf Jahrzehnte teurer Forschung
eingestellt aber es sieht so aus als ob
die Branche erkannt hat dass autonomes
fahren in jeder Situation auf jeder
Straße und in jedem Wetter noch sehr
weit entfernt ist vielleicht wird man
daher auch einfach vorsichtiger
schichtet um und sucht nach neuen
Business Modellen und da landen wir bei
autonomen Bussen und LKWs die müssten
nicht auf jeder beliebigen Straße
sondern nur auf vorher abgesteckten
Strecken fahren können LKWs müssen nicht
einmal mit dem komplexen Stadtverkehr
klarkommen wenn sie zwischen
Knotenpunkten unterwegs sind und das
würde uns wahnsinnig weiterhelfen allein
in Deutschland fehlen zehntausende
Lkw-Fahrer ein Problem das durch
autonome Trucks gelöst werden könnte in
Deutschland und den USA gibt es dafür
bereits Test und Forschungsprojekte
aber auch autonome LKWs und Busse
benötigen natürlich Energie um von A
nach B zu kommen und da sind wir wieder
beim Stichwort Energieeffizienz
energieeffizienz ist auch bei euch zu
Hause wichtig wenn ihr zum Beispiel euer
E-Auto laden oder einfach nur die Wäsche
machen wollt und hier kommt tippe ins
Spiel ein flexibler Ökostromanbieter der
euren Energieverbrauch revolutioniert
und uns dieses Video hier ermöglicht hat
die Tipper App stellt euch nämlich euren
Verbrauch in Echtzeit zur Verfügung und
verschafft euch zudem einen direkten
Einblick in die Preisentwicklung jetzt
gerade auf dem Strommarkt so könnt ihr
die aktuellen Preise der Strombörse
verfolgen und Strom gezielt nutzen wenn
er gerade am günstigsten ist das spart
nicht nur Geld sondern schützt auch die
Umwelt da günstiger Strom meist aus
erneuerbaren Energien stammt
mit Tipper zahlt ihr nur den aktuellen
Marktpreis und eine transparente
monatliche Servicegebühr um euren
Verbrauch genau zu erfassen gibt es den
Tipps das Gadget könnt ihr einfach an
euren digitalen Stromzähler anbringen
und auch in Daten werden verschlüsselt
an die App übermittelt wo sie live in
einem Graphen dargestellt werden den
Preis könnt ihr euch zum halben Preis
sichern denn wenn ihr den Code Watson
bei der Anmeldung eingeht erhaltet ihr
einen 50 € Gutschein für den Tipper
Store und damit unterstützt sie auch
noch uns und unsere Videos der Wechsel
ist kinderleicht und dort nur 5 Minuten
der Vertrag hat übrigens keine
Mindestlaufzeit und eine Kündigungsfrist
von nur zwei Wochen ihr könnt tippe also
einfach ausprobieren ohne euch lange zu
binden wenn ihr mehr überfahren wollt
und wie ihr mit flexiblen Tarifen Strom
sparen könnt dann schaut doch mal auf
dem Zimmer YouTube Kanal vorbei dort
produzieren wir gemeinsam eine videorei
darüber wie der Strommarkt eigentlich
heute funktioniert und was ich in
Zukunft verändert den Link zum Kanal
findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung
okay zurück zu unseren autonomen Autos
LKWs und Busse sind schön und gut auf
jeden Fall aber ich würde ja schon ganz
gerne mal in einem echten Robo Taxi rum
Cruisen wenn dann mal die technischen
Hürden aus dem Weg sind wird es solche
Dienste dann auch in Deutschland geben
wir haben natürlich keine Zauberkugel
mit der wir in die Zukunft gucken können
aber wir haben den Experten Professor
Peters und seine Einschätzung ist nein
die Städte in den USA sind dünn
besiedelt und haben nur ein kleines ÖPNV
Angebot daher lohnen sich die Taxis dort
rein wirtschaftlich im Gegensatz zu den
Städten hier und dann kommen noch die
technischen Probleme hinzu wenn wir mal
die Wetterdaten von Phoenix und von Köln
vergleichen dann wird ganz schnell klar
warum die Taxis hier eher mehr rumstehen
als fahren würden es wäre cool wenn wir
falsch liegen und wenn dann gibt es
natürlich sofort ein Video dazu aber
gerade sieht es tatsächlich nicht so aus
als würden wir in wenigen Jahren
komplett autonomen unterwegs sein es
gibt einfach zu viele Ausnahmefälle und
Sondersituationen für die ki-systeme
noch nicht ausreich trainiert sind die
immer nächste neuen hinter dem Komma für
die Fahrsicherheit muss einfach immer
wieder erreicht werden warum müssen wir
unser riesiges komplexes Straßensystem
immer weiter herunterbrechen auf
möglichst überschaubare Situationen mit
einfacheren Aufgaben also weg von einem
Auto das alles kann hinzu verschiedenen
Fahrzeugen mit bestimmten stärken die
Bussen oder LKWs auf festen Strecken
oder autobahnpiloten so jetzt sind wir
alle auf dem aktuellen Stand mit einer
neuen Jahreszahl als Vorhersage halte
ich mich jetzt aber besser mal zurück
schaut euch hier gerne unser Video über
leider Sensoren an die ja für autonome
Autos sehr wichtig sind und bis dahin
bleibt neugierig euer Patrick